we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors hydrant is the delicious fruit
drink powder
packed with essential electrolytes for
hydration
and it's more cost effective than
expensive sugary sports drinks
to get 25 percent off go to drink
hydrant dot com slash pacman
and use the code pacman steadymd lets
you maintain a meaningful long lasting
relationship with a primary care
physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99 dollars a month with no
other fees or copays visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
it is a big day today or yesterday was a
big day
uh donald trump conceded the election to
joe biden now i'm not going to click
bait you guys
donald trump did not say i concede to
joe biden that is not something donald
trump is likely to ever say
but what donald trump did say yesterday
is listen i'm still suing people
but my administration is going to move
forward and allow
the formal transition to take place for
now
this is donald trump and this is the
closest we may ever
get to a concession from him he's not
saying he lost he's not saying
biden won he's still going to file
lawsuits but
he is allowing the transition to start
which frees up
money for joe biden to start the
transition and he reportedly did this
after being told by
close confidants including his chief of
staff mark meadows
it's time to start moving on there is no
path there's really nothing else it is
time to start moving on now recall
that donald trump was holding up the
transition um
that was emily murphy from the gsa's to
sort of formally put in place
this is the general services
administration
they didn't start the process emily
murphy is a trump administration
official
trump had not directed her to start this
process because donald trump hadn't
conceded and the pressure
continued building and finally after
weeks yesterday donald trump tweeted i
want to thank emily murphy at gsa
for her steadfast dedication and loyalty
to our country
she has been harassed threatened and
abused
and i do not want to see this happen to
her her family or employees of gsa
our case strongly continues we will keep
up the good fight and i believe we will
prevail
no you won't nevertheless in the best
interest of our country
i am recommending that emily and her
team do what needs to be done with
regard to initial protocols
and i have done i have told my team to
do the same
so for donald trump this
is admitting defeat this is the
concession
nothing else now needs to happen nothing
else needed to happen
even without this even without the
formal transition joe biden would become
president on january 20th
but now there is simply nothing else and
donald trump says he will keep fighting
he says he still thinks he won he's even
saying he thinks he will prevail
but he is allowing the process to start
now on the other end of this
emily murphy wrote a letter to the biden
campaign
and it is just comically unprofessional
and self-serving um it is all about her
which i guess runs in the trump
administration emily murphy wrote that
all the media reports about her are
wrong she was not acting politically
she did nothing incorrect she has to
ascertain the apparent results of the
presidential election
not impose the president-elect on the
country
she points out she doesn't certify the
winner
she doesn't pick the winner there were
legal challenges and i have to tell you
guys
this is all complete and utter nonsense
she
claims she can't do anything until
results are certified that's not true
in every election the results are not
really
truly fully certified until the electors
vote in december
and yet somehow in 2016 gsa
started the transition in november in
2012 there was no
transition but the results were were as
far as the gsa was concerned
clear within days of the election same
thing in 2008 same thing in the year
2000 this is absolute and total nonsense
the whole letter that she wrote
is a self-aggrandizing mess which you
can read in full if you're so inclined
i don't find it necessary to give you
the full contents of the letter today
bottom line is this uh donald trump
had close aides go to him and say it's
time
we have to move on the this there's
really nothing else that we can do
donald trump without saying i lost fair
and square
without saying joe biden will be
president he said
go ahead and now she says emily murphy
go
ahead and this is this is it this entire
interim period will be an asterisk
in the history books of one of the most
dystopian authoritarian attempts
to steal the election it will obviously
be unsuccessful
we knew weeks ago that it would be
unsuccessful
and now with the start of the formal
transition 6.3 million dollars is freed
up for joe biden's transition
another million is freed up for what's
called a pointy
orientation bing bang boom things are
moving ahead fully and completely at
this point in time
this is the closest thing we are ever
going to see to a concession
from donald trump trump has been urged
even by many republicans to start this
transition more formally
it's not clear donald trump is really
listening to those people
it seems some of his closest aides came
to him and said
you've got to do it you really should do
it and it is happening and we are one
step closer
uh to moving on from this national
nightmare of a complete and total fiasco
and the questions that remain
are really um uh sort of academic
questions right
what will donald trump do between now
and january 20th
will we see him return to the public eye
in any capacity
today he'll be doing some kind of
thanksgiving
turkey ceremony or something like that
with melania will he ever take questions
again will he attend the inauguration
will he ever invite joe biden to the
white house we don't have the answers to
these questions
the the answers are largely irrelevant
to the broader priorities
of the country at this time joe biden is
moving forward he continues to make
cabinet selections and that's what i
want to talk about next because this is
really important
joe biden is going full speed ahead with
his cabinet yesterday we talked about
three selections secretary of state
national security advisor and ambassador
to the united nations today we have
three more actually four more to tell
you about which i will do momentarily
and as great as it is to see joe biden
do this it is also fascinating to watch
the car crash of donald trump
just being so triggered by joe biden
moving ahead
and selecting his cabinet yesterday when
i told you about three of joe biden
selections
i mentioned some tweets that donald
trump sent over the weekend
about how mad he is that joe biden is
moving ahead
uh as joe biden continues to make
selections donald trump continues to
tweet despite donald trump having
effectively conceded the race by telling
the gsa
to move forward with the transition
donald trump tweeting
in certain swing states there were more
votes than people who voted
and in big numbers now since rudy
giuliani has said that's actually a bit
of an exaggeration trump going on to say
does that not really matter
stopping poll watchers voting for
unsuspecting people
fake ballots and so much more such
egregious conduct
we will win and with every announcement
from joe biden
another tweet from donald trump claiming
he will win
so we now have the privilege and i
really consider it that
that after four years of playing defense
and nonsense every day from this
administration
we are starting to get back into
media and substantive politics
selections of people
who are actually qualified to be in the
positions for which they are being
selected
and let's review where we are so far
with joe biden's choices
of course vice president kamala harris
that we knew she will be the first
female
president or vice president uh and a
very
interesting selection um one that
in some ways progressives are fearful of
in some ways progressives are welcoming
we know about kamala harris we knew
about donald uh
joe biden rather's chief of staff
selection ronald klain
who will be a very boring chief of staff
he will be scandal-free and i expect him
to last a while
in significant contrast to what we saw
in the trump administration secretary of
state anthony blinken we spoke about
yesterday
national security adviser jake sullivan
we spoke about yesterday
and ambassador to the united nations
linda thomas greenfield we also spoke
about that yesterday
interestingly after donald trump uh sort
of demoted
ambassador to the un and pushed it out
of the national security council
joe biden will be re-elevating
ambassador to the un to a cabinet-level
role it will be part of the national
security council i think that's
important it shows that
you are taking seriously the
relationship to the united nations okay
we knew all of that yesterday new
selection from joe biden as the cabinet
is filled out
treasury secretary will be janet yellen
now janet yellen was previously the
chair of the federal reserve
and she will also be the first ever
woman
running the department of the treasury
now you know that i am not an identity
politics guy
uh i want someone who is qualified and
there is
no way to argue that janet yellen is
unqualified
and it is powerful and inspiring and
interesting that she will also be the
first woman in that position
she is going to get a fragile economy
in the midst of coronavirus with high
unemployment
almost certainly yellen will be at the
center
of a second coronavirus relief bill
which we have every
belief that joe biden as president is
going to try to put in place
she will have a massive undertaking that
she will be walking
into on day one uh and likely even
before day one and she will be tested
right away
now in terms of yelling for markets
markets will likely uh do
do well uh as a result of this
markets early today liking this
selection
yellen is a known entity already and
of course for those who are on the right
and we're worried about
oh socialism biden the socialists the
communists
the selection of janet yellen we'll talk
about the progressive reaction but the
selection of janet yellen if you are in
any way connected to reality
should confirm that there is no
socialism or communism
going on here meanwhile there
are lots of progressives who are okay
with janet yellen
she has gone after corporate power in
the past
she went after wells fargo during the
fiasco years
she's not an ideologue and at least as
far as joe biden
is likely to pursue the economic agenda
he ran on
janet yellen is not the type of person
who is likely to get in the way of
any of it it will still be up to biden
to actually pursue debt to
pursue it some elements of it uh will be
affected by whether or not democrats
take the senate there are many ifsans
and butts but janet yellen is not
someone who will get in the way
of any of what joe biden wants to do
that he ran on
much of which was at least acceptable to
progressives okay we'll talk more about
janet yellen in the future
another very interesting selection
secretary of homeland security
will be alejandro mallorcas
first latino in this position also
a jewish man who has taken very
seriously the issue
of anti-semitism will be very
interesting to see him take that head on
as secretary of homeland security what
the policy uh questions will be right
away
include what does he do about family
separation
and the caging of children not trivial
things
that will be sorted out uh by the
individual in this position a very
interesting choice
director of national intelligence will
be avril
or avril haynes will be the first woman
in history
in that position how does she clean up
this fiasco
of lack of trust in the intelligence
community
as a result of four years of donald
trump
slamming them she has her work cut out
climate czar this is a very interesting
position
john kerry will be climate czar
now merely having a climate and
environmental czar
is a move in the right direction kerry
is super smart
one of the people i met earlier on in in
hosting
the show this position will be on the
national security council
that's important recognizing that
climate is a national security issue
this is a really great thing now one
other thought
there are really interesting identity
stories here but
absent the identity stories there
are uh all qualified people in these
positions
and even folks on the right who are not
lunatics are saying we find that a lot
of these
choices are too far left but every
single one of them
is qualified now in addition to that
there are interesting
racial and gender stories to be told
here
and i don't think that it is playing
identity politics to recognize that
we're going to do deep dives into the
politics of this cabinet once it's fully
selected
remember that these positions are
set for senate approval they depend on
senate approval
if republicans end up controlling the
senate
they are going to put up roadblocks for
joe biden for at least some of these
positions
it is conceivable that if republicans
really want to obstruct
joe biden may have no choice but to use
interim or acting appointments to get
around
senate confirmation remember that
republicans have been going on and on
about obama sat on all of these the or
rather the democratic senate under obama
for those couple of years
blocked all of these selections um we
are going to very quickly
see uh whether republicans are going to
do the exact same
same thing the upside right now is that
normal non-q anon
non-fascist non-ideological
extremist lunatic types are rapidly set
to be in charge of the country just
eight and a half weeks from now
that's a really important thing last
thought on cabinet and then we're going
to take a quick break
anti-semitism is already going crazy uh
because of this elections
there are some jewish folks who are
going to be part of
joe biden's cabinet and staff ronald
clayne his chief of staff
uh is a jewish guy kamala harris's
husband
is jewish he will have no formal role
but you know anti-semites don't care
about that
janet yellen is a jewish woman alejandro
mayorkas
is a jewish cuban guy the usual suspects
are already very upset about the number
of jews here and we are already seeing
that boil over in some of the right wing
enclaves of the internet
the groups that track anti-semitism
online are already aware of it
and that i mean listen we'll have time
to talk about that but that is rearing
its ugly head once again
let's take a quick break let me know
your thoughts
uh about some of these choices i'm on
twitter at dpakman
i got a bunch of emails people saying
david you sound sick today
no i'm just at a different different
studio different location for the
thanksgiving week
using a different mic i sound a little
different i'm not sick as of now could
wake up sick tomorrow but i'm not sick
uh we have not lost the studio we have
not been kicked out
the show is not circling the drain i am
just elsewhere this week
and we have a very very busy week of
shows upcoming
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious
fruit drink powder that you mix into
water for rehydration and they're giving
you 25
off your first order it's made with four
key electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great
it's made with real fruit juice it's
been a great part of my daily routine
for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant
immunity packed with vitamins a b c and
d
which is also very much worth trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video it is time
for hatred mail this week is a very
special hatred mail but first just a
reminder
what is hatred mail anyway who needs
dr fauci or the cdc
we get all the medical advice we need
from our second cousin's husband's best
friend's boss on
facebook patriot mail
written by patriots who hate david
pakman
because america and because
freedom okay so
there is something very special about
this week's hatred mail
and it is part of something i want to
compile for you
uh between now and january 20th let's
take a listen and then i'll explain
david we know you're a loser and a
disgrace
but it doesn't matter and i'm not sure
how helpful
publishing your videos is david pakman
has one of the most
punchable faces i've ever seen what a
condescending
in his mind loser don't worry david
you'll have
four more years on talking on trump
being a loser is your best quality
yeah i want to compile all of the people
still telling me we are going to get
another four years of trump
joe biden is not going to be sworn in on
january 20th
because i'm still getting these emails
and comments and tweets
and reddit posts and all of it and um
you know at first i naively was thinking
you know when joe biden is sworn in
these people are all going to come to a
big realization they're going to finally
realize they were wrong
no they won't they'll just say it was
rigged and biden is
an illegitimate president they're never
going to say you know what i guess we
were just wrong
we were wrong when we said when i said
trump would overturn it i was simply
wrong no
they'll say well it should have been
overturned but it was rigged and biden
stole it and blah blah
they will never concede or accept
that they were simply wrong the best way
to fight patriotism continues to be
to use the coupon code hatred 40
h-a-t-r-i-o-t-40
when you get a membership at
joinedpakman.com
you save and the hatreds cry
every time that that happens i want to
talk a little bit about a piece
that joel mathis wrote in the week about
how donald trump just
can't stand that joe biden is stealing
the spotlight
from him and trump's been hiding out at
the white house and at his golf courses
but that's actually making the problem
even worse
and joel mathis in his piece likens it
to norma desmond
in sunset boulevard and you might
remember uh in sunset boulevard norma
desmond is
she ends up long after she is no longer
you know the hollywood star that she
once was she's surrounded by sycophants
and enablers and yes men and yes women
long after she stops commanding any
respect sort of living out a fantasy
living out a fake
existence for lack of a better term and
the point the analogy here is that
donald trump's behavior
only makes sense if you go beyond
questions like could this strategy work
to steal the election from joe biden
does trump really think that he actually
won
pennsylvania once you get beyond those
initial questions
and you go to well what trump is doing
here is desperately trying
to cling to the spotlight both for ego
and vanity as much as fears of being
investigated and potentially prosecuted
after he's out of office
that's the framework in which this
starts to make sense
and the more that the spotlight turns
towards joe biden
the angrier that donald trump gets which
explains his tweets over the weekend
saying
why is joe biden forming a cabinet why
is joe biden moving ahead
when we still are fighting this and we
actually won
and the reality is that this is when the
spotlight should be turning to joe biden
for two reasons
number one in general when you have a
new president-elect
the president that's outgoing is called
a lame duck president that's because
while they are still president the next
four years
are going to be decided upon from an
executive
from the executive branch standpoint by
joe biden not by donald trump and so
donald trump has these waning days
during which he is president so
in general the attention now turns to
the president-elect
what is the cabinet going to look like
what are the day one priorities what are
the hundred days
day priorities etc but donald trump is
exacerbating the speed
at which the spotlight is turning to joe
biden
because donald trump isn't even working
anymore trump
stopped doing presidential work months
before the election
he was uh just campaigning not dealing
with coronavirus
not getting his pdb's presidential daily
briefings
and he's barely been seen in public
since the election he's scheduled to do
some kind of turkey thing today related
to thanksgiving
he's not actually taken questions since
the election it's probably been about a
month
since he's taken press questions we have
a 100-year pandemic
which trump all but ignored and joe
biden has a coronavirus task force
and is taking it seriously so of course
americans in the media are turning to
joe biden
if you look at joe biden and trump only
one of them is still dealing with
coronavirus
or is dealing with coronavirus and it's
joe biden so who are you going to turn
to
joe biden is the one choosing a cabinet
that is going to have to lead us out of
this mess
economically and from a public health
standpoint so of course that's what
we're talking about and evaluating is
joe biden making the right choices or
not and how are these people going to
govern
that joe biden is selecting so when
trump doesn't recognize biden's win
finally now allowing the formal
transition to start which is the closest
we're going to get to a concession from
trump
while still claiming that he actually
won he is desperately trying to cling
not just to the presidency
but to the spotlight because of his ego
and his narcissism and joel mathis does
point out
that some of this is the media's fault
by continuing to talk about joe biden's
apparent victory
and the network uh the the networks
like oan and newsmax not even using the
term apparent victor and just placating
any insane notion
about donald trump being the actual
winner
they do encourage the system to keep it
going
but it's mostly donald trump and we know
trump hates being ridiculed
we know trump hates being mocked and we
saw that with his quick distancing from
that whacked out lawyer
sydney powell when she went on newsmax
and said there would be evidence of
biblical proportions soon to prove fraud
she was instantly fired and in fact it
was one of these retroactive she never
really was working for us anyway
because the mockery is what got to
donald trump that does
actually get to him so it's possible
that more mockery of trump
will get him to more maybe to actually
use the term i concede and call joe
biden
but all that really matters is that
donald trump yesterday did finally say
via twitter
i'm allowing the transition to happen
formally even though i'm going to keep
fighting
and eventually donald trump will leave
regardless
joe biden will still become president
but it's going to be all the more
embarrassing for donald trump
in the meantime the best we can do is
all move on to talking about joe biden's
plans
his cabinet selections his coronavirus
task force
and we're doing it and i have to tell
you i
am as i've said before trump
would be better another four years of
trump would be better for the business
of the david pakman show there's no
doubt
it would be worse for the country and i
am
actually enjoying starting to look into
the backgrounds of joe biden's cabinet
picks
what is joe biden likely to do on day
one via executive order
what is biden going to do in his first
week in terms of the virus
what are the first hundred day
priorities how is biden's
uh secretary of homeland security going
to deal with
immigration policy we're actually
getting back into
substance and i heard from a bunch of
people yesterday long time viewers of
the show who have said
i you know i've been a fan for a long
time i love what you do
but i am already feeling a breath of
fresh air and just getting back to
talking about policy even if we don't
agree with everything joe biden does
certainly we will not
uh the guy who looked at the solar
eclipse his time is up
the guy who suggested bleach injections
sort of like a cleaning to treat the
virus
he is going to be leaving the guy who
used the sharpie
to adjust a hurricane map for political
gain
he is exiting stage left in eight weeks
and we are all the better for it
and uh we are we are going to continue
moving forward and i am glad to say
that uh hopefully progressive media is
on the path
to becoming dramatically more
substantive
as we get closer and closer to joe
biden's uh swearing-in
make sure you're following us on
instagram at david pakman show
and while you're there you can follow me
on instagram
at david.pacman as well the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a practical
and affordable way to take control of
your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right i want to check in briefly
with you guys about the comedy of errors
that are donald trump's sworn affidavits
some of which are arguing in michigan
that the results
in minnesota towns prove michigan voter
fraud now if
if you just heard me say that and you're
confused you should be confused it makes
no sense
and i'm going to explain it to you let's
back it up a little bit
for weeks now trump and people around
him including his lawyers
continue to refer to supposedly sworn
affidavits
signed under penalty of perjury from all
sorts of different people
that prove that there was voter fraud
now i've already talked to you before
about
affidavits as evidence affidavits are a
form of evidence
it could be trustworthy it might not
affidavits might be credible or they
might not
affidavits might be admissible or they
might not they're not proof
of anything per se but when you actually
start looking at some of these
affidavits it becomes
cartoonishly farcical here is one such
example this is just one now they claim
to have
i don't know if it's thousands or tens
of thousands of these sworn affidavits
of people
reporting wrongdoing in mathematical
anomalies or anomalies as your
preference
may be for pronunciation but let's just
look at one okay
there's an affidavit from a guy named
russell ramsland
who is a supposed expert on cyber
security
in his affidavit russell attacks
dominion software which is used
on some voting machines and it claims
that there is
very suspicious activity in some towns
that are in wayne county michigan and in
their list of towns
in wayne county michigan they list
places like
spruce grove township and atlanta
township and roonberg township
all of those places are not even
in michigan as jake tapper from cnn
pointed out on twitter
spruce grove township is in minnesota
atlanta township is in minnesota
roonberg township is in minnesota
now one argument was uh
this was supposed to be evidence from
wayne county
minnesota not wayne county michigan so
the
everything's accurate it's just they put
mi
instead of mn and that's why all of the
towns that are listed
are actually in minnesota instead of in
michigan
that doesn't pass the sniff test because
there
is no wayne county in minnesota so what
we have here
is if we want to be as charitable as
possible
we have incompetence if we want
to maybe think of a less charitable
interpretation
these are straight fraudulent affidavits
the idea that they
submitted these uh knowing that these
are not even actually places in michigan
and they were hoping to deceive courts
and hoping to move some of these bogus
lawsuits forward we don't know
we may never know it's increasingly
irrelevant
this evidence supposedly from michigan
was submitted as part of a filing
in georgia the georgia results are
moving forward
and they it was supposedly data from
michigan
michigan has also now been certified and
put officially
in joe biden's column so it is all
failing but this is why
you know we really have to go beyond
there's this idea of just
throwing large amounts of stuff at the
wall and seeing what sticks and i've
talked about this before in debate
it's something called the gish gallop
you you throw a bunch of stuff
out there and just make it appear
overwhelming and make it difficult for
whoever you're trying to convince to
really go step by step
step and refute this the equivalent of
the gish gallup is just getting
thousands or tens of thousands of signed
affidavits and
you know holding them up as stacks of
paper as trump cronies have done on
television inc including his press
secretary kaylee mckennany
but what you really need to do is not
say wow if there are 10
000 of these things or a hundred
thousand or five thousand whatever
there must be something to it you just
have to dive in and start looking at it
and saying okay
let's look at this one affidavit and
then you look at it and you say
this really is nothing this is really
hearsay it doesn't really tell us
anything about
uh there being fraud it's an allegation
in many cases an allegation which even
if true
would not impact the results of this
state and you put that aside
and then you look at the next one and
then you look at this one and it lists
towns supposedly in michigan that are
actually in minnesota and then you start
eliminating
it and what do you have left you have
left the realization that joe biden won
because he got more votes in enough
states that's really it
and um these we rest assured
we're not going to have to hear that
much more about affidavits
for too much longer i have a very
interesting clip for you today
i believe it is possible that tucker
carlson last night on his program
set a record for the number of lies told
in 80 seconds this was an 80-second clip
i'm going to play for you
so jam-packed with dishonesty
and deception and duplicity and deceit
that i'm unsure i've ever seen so
much in a mere 82nd segment
this was some kind of wrap-up of sorts
of the 2020 election
where tucker carlson does seem to be
acknowledging
donald trump is not going to be sworn in
for a second term
joe biden will be president that seems
to be the context here
and yet tucker says this wasn't really
fair
and it's not really clear biden one for
real
and any kind of electronic voting is bad
so let's just start going through
and and this will take a little while
but i think it's worth it
let's actually check out all of the
false claims
that tucker carlson makes most of which
his audience accepts as undeniable
gospel let's jump in
other countries understand it they don't
use electronic voting because they know
it undermines confidence in democracy
okay so we're only six seconds in my
friends
and tucker carlson says other countries
don't use electronic voting because it
undermines confidence in democracy
that is a lie it is not true that other
countries don't use electronic
or internet voting it is used in
argentina
australia belgium brazil
canada estonia france
germany india italy namibia
the netherlands norway peru switzerland
the uk
venezuela and the philippines that's i
think uh 20 20 25 23
countries or so uh lithuania and
malaysia are in the process
of rolling out some electronic voting so
it is
a lie that electronic voting is not used
elsewhere
and it is used in countries that are all
over the spectrum
in terms of level of development all
over the spectrum in terms of
culture size wealth so that's the first
lie
six seconds in it took me a minute to
refute it so you understand why this is
so difficult
let's continue a system cannot function
if no one trusts the vote
and that's true here too as we're
finding out going forward we need to
find out exactly what happened
in this month's presidential election so
tucker there says no one trusts the vote
and we need to find out what happened
this is part of the story that we just
have no idea what went on
and until courts weigh in uh uh
we're just not going to know anything we
know what happened joe biden won he won
by way more
than trump's margin of victory in 2016.
joe biden won
with a 6 million popular vote victory
donald trump won
electorally with a 3 million vote loss
in 2016. we know what happened
the uncertainty is part of the deception
let's keep going
we need to find out no matter how long
it takes the investigation to unfold or
how much it costs
and once we get answers from that
investigation we ought to revert
immediately to the traditional system of
voting
the one that served our democracy for
hundreds of years what we're doing now
is not working there is no evidence
that what we're doing now is not working
that is untrue
this is literally retrograde
conservatism you know the idea of
just doing things the old way for the
sake of doing things the old way
for no real reason go back to what we
used to do period
this was a highly secure election by all
serious measures
trump's head cyber security guy chris
krebs was
fired for acknowledging this was a
relatively secure election
certainly none of the errors or problems
affected the results that he was fired
okay tucker is lying to you
let's keep going that's an
understatement as of tonight the state
of new york
still hasn't managed to count the votes
in five house races thanks to mail-in
voting
so there tucker carlson says thanks to
mail in voting the full vote hasn't yet
been counted
in some new york house races now
remember
we were talking about electronic voting
this entire segment
was about electronic voting and now
tucker pulls in
out of nowhere mail in voting he's not
actually saying get rid of mail and
voting right because that's been around
for a very long time that's not new
that there was just more of it this year
because of the pandemic
so this is tucker deliberately or maybe
through ignorance i don't know
mixing electronic and mail-in but none
of this segment was even about
mail-in voting now it's true there is
not yet a full count in
from some new york house races that that
is accurate
that's more because of the rural nature
of large parts of new york and new york
specific rules
it's not because of mail-in voting in
principle and it's certainly
not because of electronic voting which
was also the subject of this segment so
again
very very deceptive that's a disaster
let's stop pretending that it's not
but at the same time we shouldn't let
our focus on voting machines distract us
from
all that happened earlier this month the
2020 presidential election
was not fair no honest person would
claim that it was
fair on many levels the system was
rigged against one candidate and in
favor of another
and it was rigged in ways that were not
hidden from view
we all saw it happen so if this election
was rigged it was rigged in favor of the
incumbent donald trump
in a sense it's always rigged in favor
of the incumbent because of the power of
incumbency we've talked about this
before
tucker is not telling you that though
he's just generally saying
it was rigged for biden and then he gets
into
some real whoppers in explaining what he
means by that
the media openly colluded with the
democratic nominees
joe biden and kamala harris refused to
explain what they would do if they were
elected
that's never happened before in any
presidential election in american
history
but the media allowed them to do it so
of course
that is completely false and ridiculous
joe biden and kamala harris explained
just about everything
it is true that joe biden refused to
answer yes or no
would he expand the court he made a
political decision not to answer it
he is not going to expand it by the way
i think everybody
i've been saying that for months and i
think it's abundantly clear at this
point
but the person who never had to actually
explain their ideas is donald trump in
2016
every time trump was asked how will you
do this the numbers don't add up
doesn't make sense it's not clear it's
not even clear it's legal in some cases
trump would mutter some nonsense and say
we're going to figure it out i'm gonna
put the best people in and he was
allowed to get away with that
in 2020 trump didn't even run on policy
he just ran
every rally was i'm great we've done
so great and joe biden is sleepy so
tucker is right one candidate never
explained policy
but it was trump not joe biden so the
point here
is look at how long it took for me to go
through the lies
just in an 80-second segment of tucker
carlson
this is why it's hard to counter the
disinformation hopefully doing this is
useful to some degree obviously it's
outside of the scope
you know to counter an hour of of tucker
a day
would take me four hours right it's not
practical but just as an experiment
because we had this jam-packed 80
seconds riddled with lies
understand how difficult it is to
counter the disinformation
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so we're continuing our coverage of this
sort of up and down
hot and cold reporting of so-called
election fraud that's been taking place
on fox news and we are now getting to
laura ingram we talked about tucker
carlson earlier today now we're going to
talk about laura ingraham and this is
really very funny
you are going to see video now of laura
ingram
very slowly and carefully and gently
explaining to her audience donald trump
is not getting another four years joe
biden is going to be the president
of the united states and this is so
funny because it's sort of like
it's like a mid-level mafia guy having
to go in and tell the godfather things
didn't go so well
or you know an employee having to go in
and tell their intimidating boss
that they're not going to make the sales
target for the
quarter or something like that you know
tiptoeing around the tooth
listen sir we we really put in our best
effort
it's starting to look like maybe through
no fault of our own
the bad guy might have gotten away or
something like that
and she has to speak to her audience
almost like they're
not all there but she does tell them
i would be lying if i kept pretending
that donald trump was going to figure
out how to get a second term now
where she is still being deceptive is
that it was just as deceptive two weeks
ago to pretend like donald trump might
be on his way to a second term we knew
he wasn't
but take a look at this video this is
laura ingraham explaining
that thanks to donald trump as i already
told you
formally okaying the transition to start
it really is like a concession take a
look president trump
gave the go-ahead for the transition you
see it there
and as unpleasant and disappointing as
these past three weeks have been to so
many of us as much as we wish things
were different
this is where things stand tonight now
legal challenges continue in a number of
states
serious questions about vote counting
poll watcher
access are outstanding but unless the
legal situation
changes in a dramatic and frankly and
unlikely manner joe biden will be
inaugurated
on january 20th now to say this
does not mean i don't think that this
election
was rife with problems and potential
fraud
and to say this does not constitute
being a sellout to the conservative
populist movement that i've been
fighting for for i don't know 25 years
you know how some people sometimes get
mad at me
when i issue these disclaimers when i
cover certain stories i'll say you know
listen i'm going to tell you an example
of a fox news
a reporter telling the truth but this
doesn't mean we like fox news now when
it doesn't mean i'm in favor of fox news
listen to the disclaimers that laura has
to give
to protect herself from the fox news
audience which
what's fascinating is fox news has so
dramatically radicalized their own
audience
that the fox news audience is now too
radical
for any truth to be given to them on fox
news
if they say as some reporters did
earlier on
trump lost joe biden's the
president-elect
the fox news audience is so radical that
they bail and they go to newsmax or
to oan and laura ingram has to say guys
i'm not selling out really
i'm for the conservative movement but
sorry sorry joe biden is going to be
president don't kill the messenger don't
go out i'm just the messenger here
and as i was watching that's what i was
thinking about and and the other thing
by the way
imagine being someone who
you're watching this episode last night
and this is the first time
you're hearing anyone say to you joe
biden really is going to be president
like we know trump convinced 86 of his
voters
that joe biden actually stole it and we
know donald trump
convinced 60 percent of his voters that
these bogus legal challenges
really are going to overturn the
election results i'm imagining
someone who hasn't paid attention to
actual news for the last three weeks
and thought trump is about to overturn
this thing
what are they going through turning on
laura ingram last night
and being devastated and shocked to hear
that on november 23rd for the first time
they are being told guys joe biden
really is going to be
president bizarre alternate universe
that some people are living in
let's watch a little bit more of this
and she keeps doing these
hilarious disclaimers and apologies uh
and it does not mean that i disagree at
all with the president's right and
obligation to pursue
all legitimate legal challenges to this
outcome
to say this constitutes living in
reality
and if i offered you a false reality if
i told you that there was an
excellent phenomenal chance that the
supreme court was going to step in and
deliver a victory to president trump
i'd be lying to you now you've known me
for a long time now and
you long you know me long enough to know
that i will not lie to you or simply
tell you what you want to hear
the funny thing is all these fox news
people
have been offering false realities for
weeks
she it's like performance art she says i
wouldn't lie to you
i wouldn't deceive you i'm not going to
tell you as of november 23rd
yesterday that donald trump really has a
shot
but what she and tucker and hannity have
been doing for weeks is exactly that
it's no more wrong now than it was two
weeks ago
uh when they were saying here is donald
trump's path here is the way that donald
trump could ultimately be president
you had to be a fool to fall for it then
just like now it's no clearer now than
it was two weeks ago that
of course joe biden is going to be the
next president he's been
the apparent winner for going on a month
or just short of it
i am curious to see what fox news
uh sort of looks like over the next
couple of months how much do they
continue
to cow tattoo and placate their more
extreme audience the types of people who
for the first time ever were hearing
yesterday from laura ingram hey guys by
the way
joe biden's going to be the next
president there is a really big deal
being made out of a breaking story from
investigative reporter carl
carl bernstein of woodward and bernstein
fame
about 21 republican senators who
privately have been saying
anti-trump things and i am here to tell
you
i do not care if they don't say it
publicly
and they didn't say it publicly for the
last four years
who cares that they were privately
willing to say it to carl bernstein
um you know there's a couple
possibilities here
either they weren't saying it publicly
because for a while they supported trump
or they weren't saying it publicly
because they thought that it was better
for their own careers to shut their
mouths
either way their silence was terrible
for the country for the last four years
but we'll come back to that okay carl
bernstein tweeted yesterday and
dozens of articles were written about
this the 21
republican senators who have privately
expressed their disdain for trump
are portman alexander sas
blunt collins murkowski cornyn
thune romney braun young
tim scott rick scott rubio grassley burr
mcsally moran roberts and shelby
of the people on bernstein's list some
did actually criticize trump publicly
like
ben sasse uh john cornyn occasionally
lisa murkowski certainly mitt romney but
i have to tell you
i'm finding myself completely
underwhelmed by this
donald trump has represented an
existential threat to the american
system of democracy and government and
way of life
for four years a couple of senators have
mildly criticized donald trump
and even the ones that did a little more
harshly
mitt romney for example you know john
kasich
within days of joe biden winning they
went
right back to saying my goal is stopping
medicare for all
we've got to stop tax increases we've
got to deal with the debt
we have to you know reduce business
regulations so if anyone expects me to
praise republican senators who privately
criticize donald trump give me a break
guys
imagine if from day one of this
presidency
or six months in you know whenever it
was abundantly clear to everybody that
this was a disaster
imagine if early on 21 republican
senators
had actually stood up regularly and
strongly
criticizing donald trump that actually
could have made a difference instead
now that joe biden has already won we
hear oh
21 of them said things in private about
trump to carl bernstein give me a break
these people are pathetic now one other
aspect of this
trump and republicans love to say it's
the left that doesn't allow
dissenting opinions and it's the left
that doesn't want to engage in the
battle of ideas
these 21 republicans if it is true
that they really didn't like what donald
trump was doing
they partially stayed quiet because they
were too scared to say anything
they were afraid of being outed publicly
as not liking donald trump when trump
was still riding high
this is what we call profiles in
cowardice
they aided and abetted trump
and if indeed they felt this all along
they have to be held accountable now for
how donald trump has debased democracy
for four years and
i mean think back to impeachment guys
everyone but romney who did vote to
convict on one
count on impeachment if these other 20
republican senators
had voted to convict trump on
impeachment
they'd have been able to remove him and
they wouldn't have had to worry
about the repercussions of coming out
against donald trump
truly pathetic none of these people
should be held up as heroes
in fact what they are is disingenuous if
indeed
nearly half of the republican senators
in the senate
privately were disturbed distraught and
against what donald trump was doing
what they need to be uh uh sort of uh
what the what we need to be pointing the
finger to
um is that they were completely
disingenuous in public and continuing to
support donald trump completely pathetic
i'm glad we learned about it these are
not heroes these are not our friends and
as we saw from mitt romney
and john kasich within 24 hours of the
election they
obviously and predictably as we've been
saying for years
went right back to the exact type of
republicans they were
before donald trump we have a voicemail
number and that number
is 2192 david p
uh we got a voicemail from the eggman
with a prediction
for 2024. he wants to bet
people about this take a listen to what
he had to say
hey dave i like to bet on politics and i
won
on this presidential election even
though i'm not getting paid by the
schmuck who owes me because
he thinks you know trump is going to win
in court anyway i've got a bet for you
or for
any of your listeners yeah my pillow
2024.
mike lindell my pillow 2024 is going to
run
in 2024 he's not going to win he's not
going to get nominated at all
but he's going to be one of the morons
in the beginning okay
anybody want to take me up on that bet
i'll bet anything
i guarantee you this guy is going to run
for political office president
shalom brother okay um i don't think
eggman is wrong i i think that so if you
don't know who eggman is talking about
there's this guy mike lindell from the
company mypillow they sell pillows via
uh television commercials he is a big
trump supporter i believe he said trump
was a gift from god or something along
those lines
he was put front and center at some of
these early coronavirus
press events as someone who was going to
be making masks and contributing to the
effort in some way shape or form okay
etc etc
guy's completely out of his mind and he
recently donated a bunch of money to
kyle rittenhouse's um
bail to two million dollar bail money as
we discussed yesterday on the bonus show
and eggman's idea is that he may
actually run for president
i i don't think that that's out of whack
it wouldn't be unlike
um a pizza man herman cain who has since
departed
this earth due to coronavirus it
wouldn't be like some of these other
kind of edge case type candidates
who um are trying to get some publicity
i mean listen that's kind of how it
started with trump we don't we don't
really believe
trump thought he was going to win or was
even interested in winning early quite
quite frankly
um but i think eggman may be on to
something i would be completely
unsurprised if mike lindell
does run for president i agree with
eggman i don't think he would win
uh curious to hear from you if anybody's
interested in betting with eggman uh i
guess get in touch with him
uh on the bonus show today there is this
viral video that has been going around
of a trumpist a a vile trumpist
deliberately sort of like powerfully
exhaling
on people um outside a trump golf club
and he has now been charged with simple
assault
for that i guess the idea of course was
to scare someone that he may be trying
to give him the virus
we are going to talk about the reaction
from the oil
industry to joe biden this issue of oil
was a big issue during the campaign and
a big topic for donald trump during his
rallies
and we are also going to talk about the
surge
in cannabis related stocks in the market
as a result of joe biden winning and
we'll talk about what we might actually
see in terms
of legalization decriminalization during
a
a biden administration very very
um there are dramatically different
views as to what joe biden is expected
to do if anything
on decriminalization and legalization
and we'll be discussing that on today's
bonus show
two ways to get instant access to the
bonus show number one
very simple the preferred way get a
membership at joinpakman.com
takes under a minute very very strong
way to get access to the bonus show
other alternative become a patron at
patreon.com david pakman show we'll
speak to you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
hydrant is the delicious fruit drink
powder packed with essential
electrolytes for hydration
and it's more cost effective than
expensive sugary sports drinks
to get 25 percent off go to drink
hydrant.com
pacman and use the code pacman steadymd
lets you maintain a meaningful long
lasting relationship with a primary care
physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only ninety nine dollars a month
with
no other fees or copays visit
steadymd.com
pacman to get started blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman